[Musique]
mais venus à sans filtre le podcast on
parle lorsqu'on veut que nos invités
date si tu perds jusqu'en terre avec moi
de dôme plantes
cette semaine on a aussi mode la voix
aussi connu sous le nom de mode
rodez grèce alors bien sûr on est revenu
sur l'expérience expression 2 août si
vous avez peu que théo des s'ils
voulaient rien savoir dos des bas mais
sinon c'est le fun c'est le fun de
parler quelqu'un qui vient sortir de ces
expériences le sait quoi sa vie
maintenant qu'est-ce qui a changé
qu'est-ce qui est au d r changer pour
réel comment la vie qu son expérience
vraiment en montagnes russes une belle
personne personne vraie authentique
honnête je parlais fin de journée avec
sue pas simple alors on a aussi des
petits scoops quelques empreintes ces
temps ci alors restez à l'affût
ouais et si vous aimez ils s'en fichent
pas de casque ça vous tente de nous
encourager
on a une page pétrone dans le fond
petter hansson plateforme ce que vous
abonner à chaque mois pour avoir accès à
du contenu exclusif en fait avoir accès
premièrement au podcast en avance avons
accès à des coûts est né et des podcasts
de mémoire fait qu'axel tente en fait on
essaie d'en faire le plus possible à peu
près 2 par mois
sinon vous pouvez aussi poser des
questions aux invités vous pouvez en va
sûrement faire des guérillas en est avec
le monde de paix tuân donc faire des
petites assemblées live donc je me
souviens du pq on dans la décision de la
vidéo et sinon abonnez-vous à notre
chaîne youtube parce qu'à chaque mardi
on continue à sortir dé nouveau podcast
écrit vers les commandants cette vidéo
si qui voudrait qu'on reçoit qu'on
reçoit moins c'est ce que ça marche ça
marche avec écrivez ça en bas puis nous
dans le fond est en processus de compte
de recommencer à bouquet plus de monde
pour les podcasts fait que on prend vos
conseils vos commentaires et vos
conseils
sur ce bonne écoute d'athlète membre de
caste
[Musique]
salut tout le monde c'est moi juste un
petit mot pour vous dire qu'à la fin de
ce podcast
si on veut mettre un extrait du podcast
exclusif à nos membres pétrone qui
sortent cette semaine
donc soyez sûr de rester jusqu'à la fin
et d'écouté se tue pas sa joie et si
jamais vous aimez ce que vous entendez
vous c'est le temps d'aller sur pet
urnes pour avoir accès à tous les autres
pas de casque exclusif consorts là bas
et aussi nous encourager tout en faisant
partie de notre communauté pétrone le
lien vers la description si vous
l'écoutez sur youtube mais si vous
l'écoutez sur balles à dos en ce moment
puis vous avez juste ma voix est bien
allé sur pétrone points comme patanok72
24 et vous allez pouvoir écouter ça
avant 10 sur ce bon podcast avec mots la
voix monde la voit et c'est ballack son
nez on est juste trois personnes qui
parlent comment ça vous tenterait bien
mon coup de coeur on dit et le hockey ça
va bien aller
non mais c'est pour ça qu'on aille vite
et c'est parce que c'était vraiment la
marque et dans celle ci on le chauffe
eau
c'est sur qu'il faudrait qu'ils parlent
du projet ton micro à quai mais ouais
c'est ça qui est bien c'est le fun était
l'invité est vraiment gentil je content
d'être là est ce que la vie tourne vite
pour toi en ce moment beaucoup trop vite
un coup trop en fait il est président ça
tourne tellement vite que je peux rien
j'ai vraiment besoin mais j'ai un
million de choses à faire mais au bout
de la ligue en vrai que j'ai rien fait
que je sais pas si on a comme plein
projet lancé par ci par là puis on peut
les prendre
on peut ne pas les prendre mais s'est
montré que je fais comme plein de petits
trucs mais je ne sais pas comment
expliquer ça va trop loin
fête à vire pour venus anormal vraiment
paul et non le tout prix commencent à
travailler oui je recommence à
travailler
une semaine après je suis revenu je
pense que moi je reste quand même
important de revenir à petit parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de vouloir tourner après
maintenant puis ça m'a vraiment aidé et
et j'ai pas tout le temps de travailler
mais un coup de schiele avoir mes
clients m'ont vraiment fait de sa grande
et aussi social tissé colle à la peau de
leurs personnages
c'est sûr et certain tourner dessus d'un
allez bon moment qu'est ce que tu as mal
déjà en fait ça fait bizarre de
retourner après un mois maintenant
qu'ils étaient venus dans ta vie ouais
c'est clair mais toi c'est que tout a
changé c'est moi c'est changer de
blondes changer de ville suit donc comme
suit 1 des blancs une blonde a changé de
ville changer d'apparence changer dé
toutes les filles c'est comme changer de
régime alimentaire
non c'est une grâce c'est clair mais le
teacher man mais ton au dessus vraiment
beaucoup de meetings
témoin j'ai eu une page meetings ou
est-ce que c'était au milieu des
meetings avec tout le monde
ouais non mais en fait cette année on a
la chance d'avoir un contrat avec et 10
pour les gens qui écoutent en audio à la
fête des guillemets car elle est chantée
pas ça comme une chance parce que je
connais absolument rien là dedans puis
il est mon but c'est vraiment de rester
moi même puis de prendre des trucs qui
me représenter je voulais pas en sortant
prendre 1 million d'ha fanfare une
troupe trojan et ses oies les propos
rêve qu'est ce que je vais dépenser à
côté par un piano
c'est un exercice pour affronter pour
faire d'argent je veux vraiment y en a
que j'ai refusé des trucs des sites de
rencontres que tu jamais été là toute ma
vie je vais pas d'en accepter de serment
tic tac est donc t'es sûrement vraiment
l' influence la créateurs de contenu
parfaite pour ce genre de choses
non mais parce que tu sors d'une
émission de dating et ouais je comprends
ouais ça on s'entend que tu étais la
seule qui c'est le batteur est
complètement c'est le bâton non mais je
vois quelqu'un sorte que je voyais un
vent aussi et occupations de je ne t'ai
pas trop les détails d'un sommet ouest
je vois pas qui va demander à quelqu'un
c'est toi et je vois quelqu'un mais l'ex
[Rires]
dont on a parlé à eau d ailleurs mais
c'est bon mais années noah c'est drôle
parce que j en parlais à lui ya sauf
chez comme firme annonce à vienne sur le
sujet tic et l'egypte lui et comme tu
peux nous en parler c'est juste que moi
j'en ai parlé avec passion depuis on a
vu une phrase vraiment plate pour lui le
temps mauvaise passe est de lui mais
pile les gens qui me voient ils me
disaient ah pour sa tournée que les
passagers jusqu'à mon maillot des
compétitions qui ont dit ça pour moi
mais mes yeux c'est un amour le monde et
que je dis moi je me suis inscrit à
occupation double pour un peu fous rires
ça parce que j'avais vraiment la peine
qui tire ça faisait peut-être 8 me
conserver ces camps intéressés puis je
suis arrivé une expérience que j'avais
envie de vie puis un court venue des je
pense qu'on avait les deux un peu grandi
de toussaint puis on s'est revus
tranquillement ça va super bien des facs
je suis pas en coupe mais ça va vraiment
bien pour se revoir pij de sa ville
c'est cool voilà donc pour ceux qui ont
peu suivi le seco se dit surtout avec ça
au 2 mai j'avais dit parce qu'en fait
quand qui a su que j'avais fait les
auditions ne savais pas que j'allais le
lui j'ai caché qu'ils avaient été prises
puis on se parlait plus avait déjà un
mois mais quand j'ai fait ma première
audition j'ai croisé et tout le monde
sait qui est bon il voyant pendant ce
temps la fin qui a su que j'avais fait
les auditions piloter y étaient branchés
d'être supprimés à vélizy temps c'est en
tout et parce que bon on a vu à la télé
pigalle et il m'a dit est assez haute et
belle maman née mathis td brosse plate
qui ont sorti juste par frustration au
pis moi je lui racontais ça on a mis à
julian dans l'émission je pensais jamais
que ça allait passer nos titres
ma vie privée mais j'essaie sa pensée
jamais béton avant commençait un podcast
pas c'est en même temps une chose que
qu'on va peut-être abordé si ce test
c'est un truc là on va peut-être
l'aborder je m'étais dit georges vrai
dire le lait soit jamais faire dire de
la ford en main par des gonades après ça
je me suis dit dans ma vie des choses
plata demandes se font aux plates pour
petit est décédé jeudi à quatre temps
très nuageux parfois on était on était à
fleurir dans les fêtes dans l'automate
floride le début de l'année passée je
pense pis j'ai fait du sport dans ma vie
la natation puis compétitif effectifs
car 15 jours jean mettons je mets mes
écouteurs pis je vois pas là pour parler
avec là j'avais je t'emmène de bercher
avec des dons bopi jeter maximum le
tiche tgt répétition maximum psg ça me
parlait puis à l'arrêté pas me parler
pas vous poser une question plein mort
pose une question pour leur poser une
question encore pendant que j'étais en
train de testostérone je me rappelle
plus les mots exacts mais comme tournée
j'ai dit ailleurs pilote indien au mali
dit j'ai fait qu'on a tant parlé
longtemps c'est pas fini ce tout pour
chier dessus de la photo m'a dit hague a
parlé parce que je peux je pense quand
même
l'entraînement est là y'avait plus
socialement quelques mois leur toiture
tonnes tout de suite dans ta job puis
est-ce que tu retournes à 40 heures
semaine d'entraînement et j'ai
recommencé deux jours pour commencer
dans le mode de décembre mais je prenais
aucun nouveau client parce que le jeu
avait beaucoup de monde et depuis je
pouvais pas gérer seul depuis l'eau à
partir de janvier je fais trois jours
dans la semaine et je serai plus de week
end puis trois petites journées mais
qu'il ya d'abord puis j'en apprends et
quelques nouveaux aussi passé par là
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est que la
majeure partie tout en maintenant bas
le pauvre est le ca commence à se calmer
mais là c'était comme un peu les
entrevues par ci par là on est invité à
plusieurs places et bien étayé bien
bonne chose qui m'intéressait aussi d'y
aller factice sociale beaucoup de mon
temps si je fais quelque chose
quelques bars week end je veux dire de
plus sorti week end quand même pis et si
c'était à saint georges de beauce
c'est sherbrooke été si loin que ça nous
a quand même deux jours parce que
voyager ensemble est habituellement oui
enfin dès maintenant parce qu'un mec qui
menaient déjà de québec et le tout se
met d'habitude nous et on se rejoint
puis j'en ai fait pas mal avec du jack
[Musique]
ada avec les droitiers icom andreck il
comme nonchalament et c'est dumas aussi
flou que six écoliers ya pas de danger
mouse et ça c'est cool
oui vous avez passé tout le temps dans
maison des exclus ensemble puis vous
avez écouté l'émission dans le cul des
exclus ouais
puis qu'est-ce que
lui qu'est ce qu'il ya j'essaie de bien
former ma question qu'est ce qui en est
ressorti de son écoute à lui tss qui est
ce qu'il ya trouvé sa platitude
ben je vais vous parler pour lui mais je
pense qu'il a trouvée mais vous devez en
parler on a pris deux fois plus d'eau
que lui disait c'est qu'ils y trouvaient
que il y avait là d'une victime qui
aimait pas sauter parce que lui se
sentait pas nécessairement comme ça dans
les maisons mais pas qu'est ce ça leur
sortie beaucoup puis même qu'on est
comme on était un peu surpris de renault
parce qu'on pensait que c'étaient les
méchas puis finalement à regarder les
émissions pitié pas tant que ça tout les
goûts étaient pas mal sur le même vol
en fait c'est à cette époque on josé que
je pense que leurs affinités marchait
pas nécessairement puis ces jo qui se
veut des plus apportent vraiment la fac
il y avait tout ça puis après mais seul
celui-ci présente comme ça il peut
comprendre que d'une formation mais lui
c'est comme sauter mais si c'est qu'il
lui met la loppsi les occupations double
samedi chicane maxime petites chicanes
ils vont transformer sans un gros
soulagement après que je connais bien
litige aussi pour un fait que chaque
fois qu'il ya des accrochages cinq
minutes après victoire 4-2 regarder
cette version les bestiaux net décalage
mais tonton aventure pile avant truc de
vieux tv où met-on la personne et moi
j'ai trouvé que ça représentait très
bien
parko ce n'est pas le cas de tout le
monde pas tout le monde qui à hawaï non
mais je veux dire par rapport à toi par
rapport à toi à dalé mais je dois
maintenant les candidats chez que tu te
maries représentait pour lui non plus si
je les aime pas vu au litre depuis c'est
fini t on les a mis mon époux amis
proches comme la toile mais mettant des
amis proches à moi son ami proche de
l'eee qui parce que j'entends toutes les
branches pitié il parle pour lui même le
métier c'est que c'est la voiture qui
avait vécu puisque vu c'était comme un
peu de choses
ouais mais moi aussi j'ai été surpris de
ce que j'ai vu des eaux liée à la télé
contrairement à ce que moi je
connaissais de lille
mais si je parle de moi et non je trouve
que ça a bien représenté même qui est
des fois je trouve qu'ils m'ont aidé non
mais tu es moi car je patine cris jean
péter une noté c'est comme ça et on
pense à noter enfin que c'est ce qui est
un bout ou est-ce quelqu'un renault au
switch lahoud rêveur mais je suis
l'épaule je voulais vraiment mon à
l'ipsi on le voit un peu que je suis les
pommes et je filais vraiment polos t je
voulais mon allée petit répit finalement
c'est par là que la production est
désactivé le président c'est à wenzhou
but c'est ce qui me fait vraiment
travaillé sur moi-même pipe switcher
mais c'est juste que quand tu écoutes
les émissions après plus de survie une
deuxième fois
j'exagère
mettez ça m'a fait un petit pincement au
début pts et quand je me voyais pleurer
j'avais une petite larme couler je dois
y opposeraient que j'écoute exor c'est
vraiment pesant mais quand même je pense
les boues qui m'a le plus touché que le
chiche parti en larmes c'est vraiment le
bout que je parle de mon ex parce que le
match ait lieu au mont dieu et j ai
beaucoup pensé l'as bopp je me dis ok
ballon sorte un gpo choix de le rappeler
pour régler des trucs parce que j'étais
sa famille j'ai couru lui puis
finalement j'en ai parlé c'est un peu
comme ce qu'on commence à se voir parce
qu'à mon sens par les pommes et les
radios passées en double que les trucs
pas si oui dans l'établissement
ma première audition
quand j'étais en vie ce face à face avec
elle j'ai tellement déboussolé que je
suis entré dans mon audition préjudice à
laquelle j'en ai une bonne à vous et non
dans le fond elle fréquente et en annexe
meta connaissais pas vraiment plus que
ce que savait dès qu'ils mettent en
paquets l'histoire non mais vite vite le
voici qui en fait moi j'ai rencontré
david a cancun il ya cinq ans qui lui
est avec dix groupes le mois chaque mois
mais rami pour les a rencontrés le
paquet c'est ça j'ai rencontré dès cette
semaine ne se paie enfin la semaine m'a
dit moi je vois quelqu'un était acquis
du bambin était précaire au début mais
nommé après la fin du jeu des relais au
début de la semaine ne s'était rien
passé va de matériel non mais le
lendemain sa tente et je vois quelqu'un
ça fait 7 8 mois mais c'est pas tes on
n'est pas un côté moi c'est comme ça qui
me l'a apporté je pense que c'est ça
aussi la vraie histoire va que dans le
fond au kaki est revenue de son voyage
et d'ibaraki truc puis qui me rappellera
que si jamais pour finalement inquiet la
journée que je partais elle à l'arrivée
pluie partait lendemain à cancun qu'elle
les amis je termine au québec
piquant que elle est revenue une semaine
plus tard et on savait pas parler on
s'était parlé moi pluie puis l'oeil le
laisser y est réglé c'est chose faite
depuis ce temps là on est sortis
ensemble 4,50 et magasins pic à
conserver ses belles heures ils se sont
revus c'est un peu long et participation
de l'ensemble accessoires que l'histoire
à la la comme j'ai volé la chjama brice
mais non j'avais aucune liste et qui
quand j'ai rencontré lui était pas là on
est à cancun qui fait avant tout le
maintien de ce taux
oui c'est ça mais moi quand je les
rencontre et ça faisait comme c'est tout
moi qui se voyait mais cette hystérie
intérieure que je pense qu'elle allait
mais beaucoup par exemple fois que tu es
el sayegh fait d'appel j'imagine la
scène aura lieu en même temps que lui
maurienne sérieuse mais c'est après
l'intermède et a eu le dessus mettez pas
la coupe officielle mais tenir ensemble
je veux des coupes et cédric après huit
mois pour s'amener avec moi puis qu'on
est ensemble comme comme jeudi cinq ans
avait pourvu
ils se sont butés cancon c'est l'été
puis ça donnait que deux ou trois buts
en onze participations de pâques
c'est ce que l'histoire était assez
récente ouais mais tu es il s'entendait
ce premier c'est de l'eau sion serait ce
que je pense que dehors l'autre tout
sauf active moi c'est ça quand je suis
revenue ces satanés conserver petit
sommet et 6 3 je sais pas si ça leur
brosser des trucs aussi du côté à alex
waters n'est pas je pense qu'on s'était
bien entendu dans les maisons finalement
j'espère bien quand je me suis attaché à
elle vraiment beaucoup
mais la situation fait en sorte qu'on
peut pas vraiment à me convaincre que je
faisais mais je l'adoré je respecte
vraiment comme personne puisque c'est un
peu cheap allemande trouvé cette année
il a les commentaires ça revenait
beaucoup que comment se connaissent et
connaissent chavez tekki mais j avais
jamais parlé de ma vie à deux gillian
gilliane du mois on avait travaillé
ensemble main de l'ange à montréal le 8
ans on se connaît les vacances et vu
peut-être si ce qu'ils ont comme à
gauche ici mais qui le fait encore jaser
avec au téléphone on n'est ce pas on est
je pense qu'on sait que beaucoup ici
dans nos dents dans les projets qu'on a
pu on en a souvent en commun aussi parce
que lamont et menottes et complicité
aussi ok on va en parler du tout ça va
se concrétiser ces faits le fait que des
dates ans après
après quelque chose si des fois c'est
autant de vécu ces deux premiers sous
des sous mais pourrait revenir sur ce
que tu disais par rapport à attirer
l'espèce d'interconnexion personnes
quant à 10 sur trois premières auditions
ça a dû faire un plus haut pour vous
deux j'imagine millions de francs aux
essais de là il y aurait quelque chose
le pitch j'imagine mais moi je me suis
fait dire après mon audition et ben en
fait tu auras paris je parlais avec
valérie p puis à miser moi je voulais
pas c'était plate à mort mais vraiment
mes auditions j'ai tellement parlé je
bafouille est piquant à chaque fois
qu'ils me rappelais ben voyons donc je
vais trouver tellement plate billets
puis sacha pigalle je pense qu'ils
étaient le nom allâh quelque chose et
finalement c'est sur quelle histoire
avec tes alex haley sur ma à aider aussi
pour eux qui est un peu du sbc le début
mais ça va marcher
ouais j'en reviens pauvres comment au
côté des filles c'est l harmonie qui
transitent par ce plateau dans les rues
un cauchemar la maison du foot l île de
man ray l'attouchement jour et la nuit
chose qu'on avait mais on sait mais même
ce qu'on sait qu'on aimait - je pense
qu'on essayait vraiment toujours su
respecter quand même parce qu'on se
démonter on habite enfants puis on veut
pas que ça soit lourde l'apec
c'est des fois il y avait des nouveaux
qui arrivent et puis il a satisfait le
costaud qui arrive est pas parce que la
personne était lourde mais t elle était
stressée sanou stressé ou à leurs facs
l'ambiance changeant un peu plus on a
essayé de changer ce tissu de bascule on
voulait pauvre offre mais pour eux aussi
j'imagine
je pense que jarrett capendu ccc
position de marc d'un peu à de fermer
deux des nouveaux abris ses godasses et
les péons partisans après quoi débit
veulent pas perdre leurs muscles
oui c'est nous qui rentrent en plein
concert moi j'ai pas tous moyens et j'ai
trouvé que j'ai trouvé que tout était un
peu prévisible compte tenu du début à la
fin on dirait qu'à chaque semaine ils
rien que ma surprise on se dévoile tout
le temps qu'elle est partie assez facile
de savoir ça aurait pu être une bonne
idée si vraiment les nouveaux y avait
une vraie chance de mettons beaucoup
mais les couples étaient tellement
former rapidement pour solide qui est
sur moi je pense que ça a été ça a été
une stratégie une stratégie anguilles
mail qui était utilisée de thé mettons
l'an passé tu regardes de mon étions à
moins qu'ils qui sera en finale les
trois qui sont en couple
ces effets conjoints porte commun
comment laventure vous c'était en coupe
change jusqu'à fin mai que j'ai
l'impression que ça à faire comme
automatiquement boom tout le monde s'est
mis en couple
ouais bah si je me souviens bien lotis
les vieilles saison d'occupation double
du cac on était petit la première
c'était les faits éliminer toutes les
gauches il est dans sa cellule et
choisissait toutes les filles jusqu'à
fin moi moi fait détester leurs
émissions là n'ont pas les moyens d'en
bas
non mais même quand ça allait mener un
bop et de l'autre mais semble 4 mettra
coupe c'était comme dans un couple eu
six en tout cas free mangane il faut les
éliminer et puis c'est comme quand tu
causes étaient quasiment désavantagés
secondes mais là je pense que j'y suis
allé ramener un bon point et l'autre
fois parce qu'on en parle et je demain
on en parle des fois qu'on joue notre
vie puis à 10 et
elle a peint à pense que le monde ils
font vraiment attention maintenant
inconsciemment peut-être parce que je
sais qu'après tu te fais pas oublier
toute une carrière d'un flottante et
hybrides où cela pouvait crier mène sa
vie au complet puis quand elle sortait
avait pas plus de 200000 comme toi
défendre instagram si admettons petit
fait détester dans une émission tu sors
tout le monde peuvent continuer à être
des descentes avis tous les jours le oui
c'est laurence et romain tandis que me
tonti l'heure de vérité in avant avant
qu'un instagram mettons le valais l'up
juste régler tout ce que tu avais avec
l'ittihad en tabarnak tirs reçus de
sûreté puis qui calait te reconnaître
mais sans mandat ils étaient deux mois
plus tard puisqu'elle aime et on sait
tout le monde
les exclus maintenant le qui retourne à
l'heure de vérité cette année ils ont un
compte instagram pis s'ils font les
caves à l'heure de vérité
ils m'ont soir juste donner un espoir de
plus posé question tout si l'impression
que les gens avaient ce en arrière de la
tête pendant l'émission le après
commencera par itunes mais il dit je
n'aimerais pas non à ce moment là mais
j'étais un mec tu le voyais qu'il y
avait plus de revenus d'envoyer des plus
stratégiques temps voyait que ça faisait
ni chaud ni froid
il y en a même qu'on a plus c'est que
moi j'ai plus remarquée en écoutant les
émissions à west ham a surpris mathon
mais je sais pas je parlais justement
d'être avec julian cette semaine payées
on disait oui on est tous les deux seuls
nous ne quittait pas petrochem fait
pénalement t & t on croyait tout là dans
le fond vu ben non ils pourraient pas
français mais oui peut le voir c'est bon
on est dans un jeu quand même puis on
n'est vraiment pas projets de ti l'on
trouve ça drôle c'est juste que nous
témoin je regarde mon tir dans vista
marche petit objet aujjar la der à la
personne tout qu'est ce que j'ai dit et
même il ya des fois que je me vois dire
je parle de jazz puis je suis pas fan du
dit harriet et judith henry petitjean
fête de partage yann formule après après
j'étais allé là bas que j'ai dit
j'ai dit des trucs point noir dans le
cadre je m'excuse voiture parce que
c'est sur le coup mostacchi s'assoit
dessus que je peux regarder ça en fait
moi non julian je pense vraiment pas non
plus que je pensais ce qui apaise est
resté le même temps les émissions parce
qu'elle a des jumeaux schiste rouge
passe pour la méchante parce que à l'est
de la misère à parler il y en a ça sort
du temps de croche puis audrey que moi
j'avoue à aller puis je comprends tout
ce qu'a dit mme et il y en a qui ont
qu'ils ont peut-être mal compris par
bouteille puis à se rattrape super bien
voir de lui depuis qu'elle est sortie
c'est fou comme un favori le monde je
pense qu'il est adorable fiston non
verbale mais alan quant à koné tapera
que c'est même pas m'échapper mais au
début mais c'est drôle alors c'est
vraiment injuste rocky tout l'été ouais
ouais
puis une fois que sort pilote une
tribune à 200 milles abonnés comment tu
vis ce ben je sais pas au début on
nettement la première semaine que je
devais faire l'historique tout ça je
pense en me prenant 1 heure 3 secondes
de phrases shake and mind tshikapa tep
le monde il fait bon d'arrêter juba la
thématique d'abord l'historique des
premiers mois certains en doutent et
history doivent être vus par we spent
ces cinq cent dix mille personnes à peu
près puis même encore le même cas que
moi je tiens comme ok si je dis quelque
chose tu es je sais que j'avais pas
d'être jugé c'est vraiment ce jeu c'est
comme à cuba était si j'ai chez moi
j'aurais bouton dans le fond comme si
juste un exemple il ya gj annoncer les
gagnants de mon concours puis j'ai
pleinement qui m'ont écrit et boy
fatigue et a des cernes
si je me suis pas maquillée une fois
pour faire de sa vie puis je m'en
foutais b oui mais tu es je réponds pas
à ce que je trouve ça drôle bus comme un
bien beau mener tout d'abord de 50 items
le matin jeudi j'ai teint mes quatre ans
je revienne québec faut que je fasse mon
histoire igel fait buter ça me dérange
pas mais tu essaie constamment surpris
il ya beaucoup plus de positif que
négatif sur soi juste des beaux messages
psychiatre le thé mais c'est son cas
aujourd'hui
négatif pas plus que les positif mais
j'essaye toujours de me dire mode c'est
un négatif sur 100000 poussent leurs
fonds sans mais oui comme pourquoi comme
on dit fatigué digestive que je fatigue
était jusqu'au bras mais c'est metz et
c'est que règles il faut qu'il faut que
j'accepte ce jusqu'au début c'est ce qui
me stresse été parce que moi la
situation la chose que j'ai dit dans mon
entrevue qu est ce qui me stressait le
plus à ma sortie c'est sauter le
jugement déjà en pis je mens est quand
même bien sorti parce que je pense que
ça vaut mais c'est vraiment c'est à
chaque fois que tu publies quelque chose
ou faut que tu penses que tu
réfléchisses à chaque mot que je vois 0
que thibault est créée juste pour pour
téléphon du des niaiseries et puis on
parle vite puis on donne des exemples
des fois ça peut blesser quelqu'un ou
c'est ce qui me stresse l eau découvrez
mal mais les saveurs je suis que les
gens s'habituent mettons à l'image que
tu projettes cité soult à titu le taf au
king maquille la faute par écrit c'est
savoir que c'était tout le temps naturel
puis la fille qui sont en crise un peu
amener les gens de thèmes pour ce puits
qui fuit pas manquer quand je me lève le
matin et non pas qu'elles ont chassé
d'apporter ça aussi piger j'en fais pas
j'en faisais pote story avant puis je
vais témoin a montré que je me le matin
l'après-midi que je mange
et non je me concentre sur une chose si
j'aime les chevaux venant faire bizarre
de jeu fétiche
j'ai pas de 2000 story par jour parce
que 2-1 chez beaucoup à dire parce que
ça me tente pas tenté pour rien fois que
j'essaye vraiment de rester moi même si
je sais les fois les jambes mais en plus
mais en plus si ça va venir mais j'en
mets poggi rien à dire ce qu'on prend
j'essaie de rester quand même tandis
qu'à moi même pour que ce que sinon j'ai
trop l'impression que les gens attendent
après quelque chose puisque j'ai pas
embarquer là dedans dit la règle et ont
deux téléskis et mettant justement ton
c'est le basket le sans brûler ta poche
puis le genre ouais c'est ça commence à
être un peu trop si j'essaie de me
coucher vraiment pas y toucher parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de la nuit puis j'ai
mis sur des mutins les alertes et des
il est les demandes des messages
honnêtement c'est minimum 50 personnes
par jour qui maîtrise ses 50 maintenant
parce qu'avant c'était 100 200 personnes
c'est tellement des messages positifs
que je voulais répondra que je répondais
le ils me répondaient plus ils
s'attendaient à ce que je continue
d'aider condensation avec eux mais l'os
parce que si je réponds je commence ça
marche pas ça marchait pas j'y réponds
du pays a continué de m'écrire fois que
j'ai arrêté et maquillés infâme de moins
mais moi cela lots et je m'excuse ont
été si je peux je peux pas non ces
gestes ont pas caché leur jeu laisse là
je réponds à projets pas sur mes photos
ce qui était on peut pas vraiment partir
comme ça sur mes photos et gély doute
j'ai lié absolument tous deux mais j'ai
dû arrêter les autorise pas parce que
sinon niveau là ça continue je vais
passer une personne passe in parce que
dalton bon me parler à moi quand je suis
sorti le je me dirais soit plus toi toi
qui es 1 - c'est le monde le monde si tu
évites suivre pour toi bien
instagram c'est pas nécessairement une
plateforme pour interagir avec
égalitaire non non ils montent de suivi
pour ton lifestyle pour la personne que
tu étais là dessus depuis est pas obligé
de leur répondre c'est bien l'avoir
compris je vois la petite tête et je
veux voir des fois il leur faut tout est
passé au crible alcom 12 ans puis à vue
avoir un truc tu j'ai tellement envie de
répondre déjà une fois j'ai répondu à
une haie et aller à la paix continue à
écrire comment respecter ce qui est tj
expliqué du j'ai répondu du mieux que je
pouvais mais tu es j'aimerais tellement
sont autant répondre mais ça marche pas
coutume est une réponse automatique son
instinct je trouve ça un personnel
tactique a le chic pour faire ce métier
mais tant mieux servi le staff niarchos
qui connaissent une joueuse de jeux
vidéo mettait
quand même connu la thalassa le monde
c'est vraiment important demande de
collabo au début de votre réponse sinon
merci mais pas de réponse est oui c'est
impersonnel mais peut-être que ça permet
aux gens de mieux comprendre à qui elle
aussi à l'oeuvre à montreux message oral
apprécié que j écrive mais à pourrais
pas me répond ah ouais parce que témoin
gimel sa g quand tu peux aussi ça envoie
directement à l'agent secret story aussi
que c'est vraiment vrai que j'ai écrit
quelques deux cent mille abonnés en
espérant une réponse c'est surtout si
c'est et hop tu te prends un compte
professionnel ou ccc plus rough un peu
dégoûté mais non merci je veux qu'ils
continuent de m'écrire m'a juste pour
espérer que je réponde à faire pour ça
parce que je pense que j'ai réalisé que
je suis sorti plus le monde il ya du
monde qui ment voilà de la chipie me
suis dit si je les blocs
je remarquerai même pas la différence
ouais mais les blacks il s'est même si
j'arrive mettons s'est jamais de la vie
je peux être bloquée 50 personnes tuées
depuis le programme big mais admettons
que j'aie en bloc mais il
c'est quoi c'est quoi le pays voire 1000
personnes mais le négatif de ma vie que
je n'aurais pas pu faire via une
taxation sur toi qui revient tout le
temps ça pollue ton temps à holt et ont
enfermé sa politesse juste tombé
quasiment d'accord maintenant les
gouvernants tabarnak pour le jeu de la
journée ouais les gars j'ai c'est à la
sortie une vidéo est ce qu'elle est avec
une petite fille vont et cochons hockey
ouais le genre c'est vraiment une couche
d ôter vraiment être une bonne bd c'est
juste des bonnes affaires qui sait pas
où cela tout le monde est content de la
vidéo plus qui commande séjour de six
maps en sexuelle préféré la petite fille
on sent qu'à l'inspection ces femmes
viennent ainsi le podcast un club tu vu
il revient tout le temps à chaque vidéo
il écrit tout temps de quoi d'absents
que j'ai commencé à bloquer report un
gars qui s'appelle the world au fc gold
et à chaque il revient à chaque pays et
qui de quoi
dans le marais place jean raquin
vorilhon ça ferait une belle escort sur
mappy lillois commenté de quoi mais j'ai
aussi un petit commentaire
je leur apprends à écrire ses golfs ont
toujours des fautes oui les jours je me
fais insulter par un gars qui aimait
tant qu il s'en est expliqué mme envoyer
chier
mais c'est sa faute juste pas se
concentrer sur les autres
ce test est resté concentrer sur ceux
qui sont positifs
je pense juste un conseil de ville
mettons des amis qui tease genre
relaxnews taux naturel versus gens
quelqu'un qui dirait gibrat ses conseils
c'était mes amis ceux qui me connaissent
mieux valu des déboires est non
seulement travailler mais wayne on
sortait d'audiffret choisi story je
serai pas à l'aise on estime à meteghan
s'est lui fait pour quelque chose que tu
aimes ça y va par là le mec à ti cats
fait quelque chose parce qu'il faut que
tu le fasses ou qu'elle est ok bah il
faut que je fasse à un arbre et le et
comme plus très flatté bon comment je
vais faire ça sans repos comme
naturellement il faut tout juste pas se
poser de questions toujours sans espaces
les premiers storrer a tancé le bon je
me dis je le pense je le fais pas ça
gagnent ce n'est pas ce que je commence
à essayer de penser oui tout ça marchait
pas comme quelqu'un faisait mettant les
uns trop podcast pour l'heure près de
huit fois leur contrat 1ère take parce
qu'à chaque texte est persistant le 16
ou le 17
trempez j'étais tellement nerveux se
montrait trop d'années c'est ce qui fait
que ce qui autorise enfin que c'est ce
que j'essaie de me dire maintenant que
même si tu bafoue uk
vraiment pas ce qui fait que le monde
s'attachent mettant ce qu'il fait que le
monde sont attachés mettons à toi c
était vrai et authentique les capacités
émotions transparaissent péter hunt dans
ta voix rassurante et triste ultime
c'est triste quand tu es fort et tu es
moche et puis ça fait qu'ils s'écoutent
attend depuis les gens même si les gens
sont plus attachés qui connaît un
parfait mais donne ait quelqu'un qui
veut vraiment bien paraître mais quel
mérite y voit qui est qui joue ses
cartes qui réfléchit trop ce qu'il fait
c'est vraiment elle vraiment beaucoup
fait que sa tâche c'est vrai puis le
questions réponses se répondent poste le
paquet d'autres sources eu des déclics
genre comme a demandé non mais j'avais
beau nom mais je pense que ce aux
messages facebook j'ai pas regardé une
demande de facebook je pense que les
gens sont plus seuls au creep on peut
transférer sur instagram les clichés qui
s'attaque aux jeux sur facebook
mais pour ne rien non j'en ai pas vu non
geithner sucre non non non et s'ils
n'ont pas reçus sauf quand on se disait
jeudi j'essaie à la même perçu davance
tu es de messages de gens parce que moi
j'ai reçus 0 ce non plus mais je me dis
que ce soir par un couple allemand qui
doit recevoir parce que chez qui
m'attend lplp à nord-sud se dénoue
j'espère qu'ils avancent mais les gosses
j'en entends parler des jeux aussi et je
pense qu'ils balaient voyez là dedans
mais non non non c'est marianne ahmad
zia qui y est je suis partagé une grosse
bise à la caisse mois 300 et 3000
personnes bien senti mal et ça paie le
juste partage est dépendant d'eux goal
com qu'est-ce que j'ai dans mon premier
sa première selon lui à dénonce même pot
tient à 10 mai mme pocq attention jean
waline quand j'ai le temps hivernal
graphique
cb ghislaine et sa première étape et
c'est peu c'est pas marianne hamas et
fait envoyer parce que le à l'elysée
jean louis alex 69 c'est lui qui avait
écrit à jesse non mais les chinois y est
allé avec raj et si je te mangerais le
cul même si tu viendrais tchié plage les
cibles et ré c'est lui qui le premier a
réalisé mais sait il avait dit je te
manger le cul même si un match nul somme
toute une photo de jesse moi je l'avais
je l'avais riposte et à une année du
love à ce que le pense clairement qu il
ya vait genre 20000 personnes d'écouter
sont liés mais si je sais le plein avec
ry a fait un four merci m
grosse graine à marianne au magro sa
graine moi je crois qu'avec mais
scarlett gros lequel répartie telle
somme en dépit des douze ans qui suivent
marina mazza mais moi j'ai juste été
surpris tu sais maintenant que demain
tout le monde qui vont ouvrir une story
marianne amateurs auront une grosse
grêle personnes ont partagé quelque
chose de voir ça
l'avez-vous c'est toute la pomme habana
marina matin
[Rires]
est ce que tu peux parler de projets qui
s'en viennent pour toi où tout est
encore sous silence tout est encore beau
juste sous silence commandes en train de
discuter mais je sais qu'il ya eu 200
articles qui ont sorti sur le module
xiamen et puis c'est des choses qu'on a
faites depuis qu'on est sorti les gens
nous demandent à chaque jour si on veut
en faire un faction ça nous motive
vraiment tourne vraiment envie d'en
faire un on a 1 millions d'idées mais
pour l'espace et se tait on en est là
mais on pousse beaucoup pillet c'est
qu'on croise les doigts on dit ouais
pilot mais tant qu'ils savent que ça
serait quelque chose qui ressemblerait
ce que faisait mon temps à autre des
sabres a fait seul quand j'ai vu que ça
va passer
jamais on s'était vraiment super qu'on
faisait nous ça a duré deux heures jeudi
on est peut-être celle des maisons pour
une fois qu on y ait des ensembles tc
vraiment on pensait jamais que ça allait
passer dans l'émission dont on fait
vraiment du montage ah ouais je sais pas
c'était kick travail et le montage n'y
avait certes un moment délicieux
vraiment fait des enfants qui a monté ça
allait vraiment tripé aussi facteur on
en reparle et qu'on est sorti puis on a
vraiment on a plein d'idées mais on
essaie de julian du mois en parler pour
défendre un début un milieu et fin de ce
conflit
on aimerait si on a plein d'idées mais
comme je dis faut qu'on essaie de temps
veut pas que sa part de quoi jespo on
essaie de s'entourer premièrement des
facs mais est ce que vous savez et c'est
une idée la plateforme celle faso est ce
que vous allez faire sur youtube ou
autre on aimerait vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment ça sur youtube mais je
sais pas si
e
c'est con parce qu'on a avec prodigits
et fa cup avec bt les petits maires et
promet tout sur nouveau me tombe bien et
très près je sais pas on est on parle de
thon sont vraiment été je m'en fais pas
confiance acte est vraiment on a comme
faut qu'on se parle avant pour justement
si on le fait et en droit d'accès des
ouï dire que nous mais nous on a plein
d'idées puis aussi j'imagine mais le
steak comme les vacances il ya un peu
surtout que la main si on en parle
depuis six ans que si si ça fonctionne
nous avait promis aussi touquet sa wii
le titre sont confiants restée jusque-là
le monde nous le demande tellement que
j'aimerais se dire oui mais tu es je
peux juste dire oui ça fonctionne pas
normal
écoutez le dans le fond avec votre
contrat avec prodigy vous pouvez pas est
ce que vous pouvez faire
n'importe quoi sur des plateformes
alternatives comme yuto maintenant tu
pourrais tu toi faire une chaîne youtube
est juste parti d'affaires ou et pense
que oui j'ai un autre match pas à mes
enfants vraiment pour cela à chaque fois
que tj voit à chaque fois que j'ai eu
une opportunité je leur en parle dit
mettez gpo com fait le tour à date de ce
que j'ai le droit ou pas de fin puis les
études t'as pas mal mais je suis peut
faire pas mal tu es si je me rappelle
mon idée qui est bonne je t'aime
empêcheront pas de faire quelque chose à
ce point lui qui était avec produits
s'établissent pour les groupes
contrainte et que eux ils vont vérifier
tout était correct si vraiment un
montant représentait vraiment ce que tu
veux vraiment faire ça ou c'est juste
parce que tu es ce cobra vaccin on est
bien entouré de ses côtés le mais c'est
beau et c'est pas mal de moi je vois
c'est vraiment positif acte et je puisse
en suspens faire et moi bien avec nous
mais avec moi surtout que je demande des
projets tels que je parle avec les
autres ou alors il me dit jamais non
t'es qu'est ce que je regarde tout à une
question fort puissant ça marche chef à
quai et si je vois pas ça comme des
bâtons dans les roues le terrain ce
matin que maintenant on georges le fait
que tu mets ton était satisfaite de
travail qui font le pot pour vous ou
pour moi oui
pour tous c'est tout ce qui est officiel
mais au moins le positif là-dedans c'est
que sa tante ou requin dans un domaine
montrent que moi j'ignorais complètement
ouais ce que tout ce qui est marketing
influence tout ce qui est personnalités
publiques saines et sauves type chips a
aucune idée des coiffeurs avec seul oui
je penserai tout perdu le sabathia
matonge avait pas eu lieu pour mais pour
répondre à mes questions mais moi j'ai
jamais été la pipe il a fallu que je
parle à la demande comme vous le
téléthon pour m'aider ce nom parce que
j'y mets d'avoir d'avoir quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de ce bail à tête fallait vous
vous trouviez l'agent parce que c'est un
email
ou de savoir combien telle affaire ça
voter un tapis négatif pour aller
chercher plus et jetez moi dans la vie
je regarde les gâter mes enfants j'ai de
la marge cadeaux gratuits lot
ça m'a aidé parce que ils vont aller
chercher même plus les questions qui m'a
dit que j'aurais pensé fac et met de
l'argent sur sa propre personne
oui c'est vraiment négocié pour soi même
mais oui mais c'est vrai que ça a pris
combien de temps avec ty temps et en
argent que ça a été ça a été long parce
que on ne
[Musique]
c'est fait on peut prendre dans un
espèce de guillon parce qu'une pétition
on fête les enfants ensemble on peut
prendre une espèce de promesses de
peut-être que peut-être que ça va
arriver de pire que ça va arriver et
fait qu'on était tout le temps comme en
attendant comme 4 5 mois on est en
attente complète
sans que jamais rien parce que là on a
juste fait qu'il faut que depuis là à ce
moment là elle paye qui était l'agent de
dalanis pi2
dlp en fait lui on a été on allait
manger avec un clown fait shenkman ça ne
prend quelque chose que quelqu'un qui
nous entourent sont ni mieux qu'on est
lorsque l'on parle de tân son nhât le
lieu précis
il s'apprête à six mois koki fait
concrètement c'est lui qui fait les
emails qui fait le backend fouette avec
les gens c'est lui qui assure que le
bleu
le contre eux soient en lien avec ton
brême des sas et la khl et y mettons 4
dans une émeute ont
il ya des sites qui font un peu ça sauf
que c'est vraiment comme du cosco pour
le marketing d'influencé sous le titre
s'inscrit sur un site appelé les
compagnies choisissent leur influence à
travers la baisse sauf que lui ces
comités
il nous connaît vraiment c'est
exactement qu'est ce qu'ils foutent de
nous il s'est quand même d'en parler
koné les chiffres et des stats connaît
que ça vaut les bacs une fois avec les
compagnies souvent ils nous amènent des
contrôles mais ces pratiques qui a
produit c'est une grosse équipe ce que
de ceux où si une personne est 103 en 3g
risques énormes edouard ce bandit mais
là à chaque jour tels j'imagine t comme
je ne suis pas mouettes témoin gersois
possible au moins 713 à moins que les
autres mettant le béton qui est une
compagnie qui décide d'envoyer 18 email
à tout le monde mais aux tirs soit 18,6
mais on aimerait ça vous avoir fait pas
le clou face mettons les choses qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui constituait le
seul à savoir pour les clous fait leur
auteur soit 8 fois
mais là où vivait son nez je ne sais pas
si j'allais si je ne sais pas des choses
qui m'intéressent pas accepter mes amis
elle est totale mais jamais en commun
comment tu prends en se mettant
promenant rupic park and ride maintenant
mais je sais pas je me demande quand je
me promène tout seul ou avec quelqu'un
qui m'arrive
thema temps une fois ci joue à magasiner
et de la chaussée ouest
mais je sais plus ce que je me sens
regarder sans arrêt j'en passe par la
shq depuis maintenant 20 que vous je
m'habitue le cema carec mais c'est ça
c'est juste me sentais comme regarder
j'ai vu joe gens trop jours après qu'il
soit sorti de route déjà au apple store
à québec
ah ouais je les dévisager c'est comme
tout le monde non mais c'est vrai que
devient jijel est en baisse de 10
j'étais là je pense qu'il dit il ça
dépend des fois si puissant guide mis au
supplice et grands mais moi je me
rappelle très bien s'est jetée à québec
j'étais au boudoir à québec d'un texte
existe encore déjà vu hubert le gall a
gagné téléphonique avec m
la belge avait vu je le rappelle avec le
suffixe j'avais fait à bardos des planes
est lui devenu le joueur méchant j'ai
repensé à ce dernier remarque je me suis
dit lui désire à stockholm arrête de me
regarde en face comment mieux si la
personne vienne parler étaient au moins
c'est comme moins encore que juste des
visages étaient si ça dépend des moments
et des moments que ça me dérange pas je
suis pas content tu venais me parlez pas
problème un autre
j'ai eu une bronchite testing 18 ch
arrive au pour attendre les payer la
formation ça c'est pas maquillée génique
coach degers l'expérience à coup tu
parles propos de lester piot déteste pas
feint une gamme et il ya des fois que
satan
the way une journée difficile - où s'est
passé quelque chose dans sa vie de sa
tante par la personne va l'être comme au
choix tdd de bonne humeur doit pas déçu
c'est non ouais mais bon je me suis avec
toi les premiers jours du camp d'aller
prendre un café là maintenant
sedan les moyens ce qu'a fait c'est
comme ça quand même où ces méchancetés
paix pour les gones savent quoi je sais
pas non mais là c'est la pression y est
fait pour une fille trouve pas dans les
bornes wifi sont plus portés à les voir
avant et après l'élection de
d'or une question de personnalité aussi
la de neuf mois maintenant
moi je pense que j'ai bon on se pose on
enlève tout surpris
comme je disais j'ai l'impression
quelqu'un qu'on voit en public mais ton
c'est vraiment plus une question de la
perception que les gens ont la personne
aux dictats moi je sais que j'avais
l'air mais ton de parler beaucoup de pas
très extraverti à l'émission pis même
après c'est sûr mais réseaux sociaux
mais je pense que le monde sont pas
porteurs mais on va parler mais généthon
quelqu'un sans drik puis adam au sort
dans un mort ou sortent en public le
monde vont leur parler de suite parce
qu'ils ont l'air social ou à l'anis
mettons oasis à mai mois le monde vienne
comme pomme parler trop parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils jouent sur leurs appareils
merci david pearce et ouais c'est que
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelqu'un
que 15 sites et tout le monde doit venir
te parler parce que tu as l'air c'est
sur wii c'est cute mais dans les bornes
on n'est pas dans le sens ouest est
patent que pendant que ça aurait fait
plus on n'a pas fait la tournée dont le
talent est là on est allé une fois la
petite grenouille charles bocquet
vous êtes un cauchemar pour moi je ne
suis pas très peu partout face à yann ça
fait un peu même chose - je me poserai
payer mais je sais pas si m sont mes
yeux je pense qu'il trouvait ce qu'omet
tout moche ouais ouais
pour commencer là mais on ne trouvait
seulement mettez lui je pense à la part
huit envisagés comme ça a été comme on
rêve toutes voit rien n'entend rien
gâter l'homme était co mais c'est
bizarre et monte pas opté comme la
roulotte et au début le ça fait
seulement ouais je sais que adam oates
andré qui a été reçue comme c'étaient
des sortants pour tous les autres années
c'est ce que c'est comme ça ouais
vraiment mais et ça n'est pas les places
en fait c'est la première place que
c'était moins pays de l'est la semaine
passée même à montréal je me situe à
montréal telle est mon
c'est un peu juste puis on est rentré en
fait personnel est rentable c'est juste
pour tout petit cube mais même pour moi
je m'arrête de bisous quelque chose
déplore paul autant d'amour tiges fait
tourner ses coûts mais t'es pas sauver
le monde et à l'accueil au début pour s
est ce que je disais j'ai fait à pau
tenté j'ai rien fait logique riche et
croyez-moi d'entre eux - telligent
comprend beauté arrêté mais à la longue
en lisant mes messages que je reçois
tout ça je me suis dit le pauvre et le
trou encore du défi qui m'écrit parce
que j'en avais statistiques nous
annoncera g g 87 % de femmes qui me
suivent la ccpo des gaules 198 les
filles me critiquer telle province pour
cent des filles sacré foule dense et
c'est avec mon gosse que julian
seulement une pression et je sais pas
j'ai pas demandé mais était ce qu'il
était mais qui sait vraiment ce c était
mon dieu mais aussi chez betty scène
française
mega express iv vite eu quelque chose
comme ça aussi petit monde texte est
folle piqueté femmes n'ont finalement tu
es je me suis compris à travers toi puis
arrivera kg je comprends un peu plus
quand les gens me voyais pas ce qui
était joseph respaud mal pleurer crier
dans ma vie je pense que tout le monde
le fait puis c'est juste qu'on n'est pas
filmé 24h de garde pour eux il ya
personne qui te regardent face à monteux
déjà pété des grosses crises le tpiy je
pense que ça l'est comme je sais pas je
réalise un peu plus tu trouves ça cute
parce que oui les gens s'assoient me
retrouver dans ok si je bois je pense
que c'est plus pour ceux annoncés claqué
j'ai été le la télé réalité oui mais je
pense que c'est vraiment la façon c'est
que ça s'est déroulé pour moi mais ils
sont reconnaissables mais je ne suis pas
le fait que ce sont que très rarement
pour ses comédies en sortant les j'avais
juste et j'ai rien fait le juge champoux
maurice fait pas médecin je suis
absolument rien puis mais un quizz sur
le coup c'était bizarre mais était de
plus en plus et se tait je pense que
c'est le monde s'attachent à toi par
rapport à comment tu réagis ou code
qu'est ce que tu as vécu dans le fond
moi j'ai l'impression que met-on si on
prend aux débats l'i way la personne qui
ressortit parce qu'on s'entend quand ce
train fantôme ex nombre de fonds loin
juste par le fait que non mais je pense
que de hauts des ben ali
celle qui s'en est sorti un petit peu
plus comme toi c'est halal est ce parce
que le monde son retour aidé beaucoup de
pays qui sont retrouvés en est exact
selon l'étude les standards de beauté et
la confiance en soi puis le cnpa au
monde mais je pense qu'elles
exerceraient relais l'examen je pense
que toi dans ton cas la raison pourquoi
même ce départ en finale le monde ont
accroché à toi c'est justement pour se
lancer des défis qui sont reconnus parce
que corrige moi si je me trompe
en fait je me pose la question en place
de faire un instrument comme ça est ce
que tu penses que à travers l'émission
toi tu as grandi dans la saga harry
beaucoup surtout embêtant pour ça j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup de monde
qui en voyant toi à prendre sur toi on a
pris sur elle un bon principalement des
fils au a pris sur elle même en voyant
comment agir une situation parce que au
début ma perception à moins
monsieur qimonda est la marque en classe
tout le monde sait d'ici 2 3 ans et
merlin gilles renaud il va partir il va
partir avec l'autre ça va faire la
grosse merde plus finalement ce qu'on a
vu c'est toi qui fais ketchup et le
droit lettres de mouvance que de rester
vraiment un teg puis ça je pense que
tout le monde qui ont dû avoir ce
message club fadoq tu peux être exprès
si tu peux réagir mais ça
personnellement non un tacle péter
j'avais déjà vécu d'autres situations
comme ça dans ma vie que j pour gérer
comme ce poteau mais on dirait que
occupation double j'ai pas ma meilleure
amie que je peux appeler pour des
limousines nana peut appeler ma mère je
peux pas tout seul avec moi-même puisque
comme pipo vrai c'est bien et parce que
j'ai genre c'est comme je veu t pas avec
maman qui exhibe annonce pokora depuis
mon ami qui nous dit que ce soit au
québec au point g gérer ça avec juste ma
perception moi même où j'avais les
filles qui m'aide un peu passés par le
tpiy qui m'écoutait mais jeudi ils ont
tous deux vécu avec moi aussi parce
qu'il parle pas travers leur chapeau ils
ont vu l'association pareil comme moi va
connu comme b c 501 j'irai peut-être
mais vraiment et pour de vrai je pense
que je serais peut-être les deux n'ont
même pas de téléphone pas de jugement
juste moi là comment je pense que ce que
je fais accès aux réactions c'est lola
mais j'ai vraiment appris puis comme bon
mais pas moi même je pense que jusqu'à
voie de régler les choses tout seul puis
de reprendre pour moi parce que je pense
ce niveau là oui ça m'avait grandin fois
mille parce que team manager puis une
chose qui me dérange un double jeu
communes petites choses qui se passent
bien oui c'est cette arrivée j'accepte
je les fais penser à d'autres choses si
ça va être correct tout comme passé à
travers toutes les phases de
d'acceptation laisser la frustration
l'adulte est impie puis torstar sorti le
vraiment résilient voilà mais c'est
tellement c'est tellement intéressant en
fait on parcourt à occupation double
thème intéressant
deux exactement parce ou alors le fait
que te fait toute la gamme puisse erreur
que meudon - cash sorti je me suis dit
wow a pas rencontré ma blonde c'était
pas mal useless le excellent parcours
lol j'ai tu as pris sur moi pas
nécessairement du collège et tu y auriez
insa mam n'est rien il était de plus
personnellement je pense que c'était le
cas pour ben du monde dans ses missions
l'action sortie c'est quand même normal
que tu t'es encore même personne mais
comme maintenant j'ai une vie différente
et on dirait que ça c'est encore une
fois tant que je me trompe mais on
dirait que ça peut changer
ben harper fait mes amis me le disent
aussi et surtout les filles avec qui je
travaille parce que c'est avec eux que
je pense c'est le plus de temps le trait
mais jusqu'à quand je parle sont comment
dieu avant et je t'explique change plus
c'est moins ça va plus je prendrai
quelqu'un a pu pour des niaiseries
ce que je sais c'est truc avec le
téléphone sonne delta travail aussi
encore là mais j'ai encore du chemin à
faire dans ma ville je vais beaucoup
même léger mais j'essaie tout employé
sur le meilleur de moi même je pense que
depuis mois justifie pas parler de ça
dans l'émission on va pas remarqué la
team et et j'ai perdu mon père est
subitement l'année passée je sais avant
de me séparer
j'ai une grosse crise chalet comme voir
des personnes pour me déplacer l'objet
comme fait le mouv de me séparer
j'avais besoin de vivre autre chose puis
je pense que deux je pense que ça a été
mon déclic comme mon père est un schéma
que dans un mois ça soit fini et je sens
un mois à stresser pour détenir l'énoncé
ça me tente pas factice et ça a été un
déclic après c'est tout plein
d'expérience je pense que tu es tout
seul ça m'a aidé et mettez en fait
encore ni l'autre de ces matins à 21 ans
j'étais impatient de je pense pas que la
motion mais c'est ça aussi c'est que
malgré mettons les crises ou les
montagnes russes où il a vu comment
t'appelles ceux ci on s'inquiète à 20
que tu un bon fond c'est piquant
quelqu'un qui est ce
andré qui ont ils pardonnent justement
ces imperfections notées ces mêmes camps
qui
tant pis ou adaptés je pense que c'est
bon aussi ouais c'est quand même en
donner dans les maisons mais je pense
que julian que mons et bien compléter là
bas parce que j étais aussi comme est un
peu et je sais pas comment le mot entre
que pour décrire ce métier moment donné
on sort lé manquer plus a dit mot tout
ceci est obligé de monter vraiment bas
après chalet dans trente secondes après
j'ai dit oui parce que j'ai répondu me
fâche est allé la voir dans un
garde-robe g didier je m'excuse si
j'étais mal répondu pas du moins c'est
ça je me demandais je m'envole en salle
d'éveil le gerbier visited jk quelques
vieilles s'est excusé du peu dire ce que
règles et j'accepte c'est assez agréable
à regarder m'a dit j'ai accepté ses
excuses mon je m'excuse mais c'est juste
des pistolets c'est drôle mais elle
aussi allée tellement trahi israël mais
oui être coté 12 2 2 c'était avec aussi
les personnages attachants bastille audi
ça s'écoute comme une télésérie matin en
asie
c'est le fun qu'un personnage un point
de départ qui a un arc et d'évolution
parce que le citoyen ait eu ce julien us
où ces mêmes renault estime peut être qu
c était drôle qu'à la fin est devenu
attachant que tout passait par stérile
gamme d'enfer le fait que tu fais un
voyage personne puisqu'il ya d'autres
personnages qui met on était peut-être
pas le le jus le jute et on peut pas
donner matériel plus narratif pas que ça
fait une histoire plus linéaire mais
comme sienne l'injustement renier cru il
ya un an de leur ouverture sur le monde
a tendance à en marquer plus s'attache
plus à toi tu lui feras plus vrai exact
plus vrai authentique mais à la fin les
gens trouvaient de route même sous moi
j'écoutais une sombre riel cd copiés
dans deux gros la crise de confiance
budget comme ça
il y avait justement c'est quand tu sors
ton casting c'est au lit je te mets un
mini peu chien une fois avec joe pilote
est la panique la grosse tandis que
renault qui fait notre niaiseries après
ça sort pas de son cas c'est une autre
on était prêté dans un espèce de
marécages à bali sommes d'argent dont la
visière en face mais c'était juste de
l'humidité le jour vous aviez la vue sur
la mémoire ça avait l'air hince est
malade
est ce que c'est ce qu'a ramené mettons
sur ça devenait ce que vous le premier
pour acquis un peu passé plat tu as well
vos menus problèmes peuvent prendre pour
acquis mais dès les premières journées
qu'on est arrivés on savait te dis et à
qui on se promet 10 comprend jamais seul
pourra qui laissera pas d'alors on peut
partir dans une semaine si le tpiy ont
capoté
mais si on essayait vraiment souvent de
se dire ça parce que tu es des fois on
était franchement blessant à lyon était
fort et on avait hâte a fini sa famille
noté ça fait deux montres avoir vu ta
femme et et et est allée tout le goût de
revenez laon d'équipés plus jamais dans
une maison on est logé nourri on a toute
la bouffe qu'on demande
la piscine était pas normal les levers
de soleil aussi telle équipe de position
était géniale t on essayait tout en te
rappeler à quel point on était chanceux
d'être là je veux dire dans un sens puis
déception c'est quand même prêté au jeu
par nous mêmes soit comptable paie la
journée que je me souhaite éliminer je t
adore religieux de l'acteur légaux
venait de déménager
on a une maison billet je le sentais
l'été j'avais perdu à se hisser à la
table on s'envoie je suis plus capable
d'y jeter année puis joli jeu l'acteur
légaux chanter le coucher de soleil que
ça devient enfin je vois c'est puis le
sait comme as tu géré du encore plus et
est allé à chaque jour que je t'ai ici
mais ouais mais tu es en direct qu'on
s'habitue à tout en devant vif inquiète
c'est ton nouveau charlie les premiers
mois du capot depuis après un mois avant
dans ton char tu t'en fous on s'habitue
vite à tout dans vif à quai ouais mais
tu vois moi j'étais juste content c'est
moi j'ai jamais j'ai pas eu un moment où
tu nous diras tu aurais déjà apprécié
les ti un nom à quai parce que c'était
vraiment ivre
c'était juste ces balises alala en scène
je sais pas à guetter j'ai aucune idée
parce que t'as pas sorties activités
d'éveil le sort du film et
d'antioxydants dans ta peau était non
c'est sur ce jeu prêté exclu non plus on
paye vraiment la grèce nous on le visite
et des exclus n'en font ils voulaient
sortir à tous les jours mais nous on ne
nous avec nous et quand ça fonctionne
sauf que si on était la nounou jo puis
mois puis on est loin de tout pendant
les deux semaines et on a fait les
tauliers de la bombe
les finalistes n'ont pas ces starlettes
à tremblant faire une autre cha le bon
nom mais charest trouver sa place
d'avoir vécu trois mois sur l'île de
crète puis de ne pas pouvoir voir rien à
part les trois ou quatre sorties dit
elle que j'ai fait
puis j'ai tout vu le de a à z en crimée
xixe au complet le vignoble
oui puis ont des fois on partait à deux
heures de route dans une petite ville
l'on allait faire le prêter dans les
bacs ont loué un hôtel là qu'on dormait
leur important joe black joe black widow
[Musique]
oui double a quitté son mari
bon j'ai dit oui mais je pense qu'avec
toi de juillet par ibm sa cbr non ils
payés par fait que je pense qu'on a eu
on ne peut nier la baisse nous nous pour
les hercules pour les exclus qui les ont
tous la salle enlèverait aux ordres ne
nous le rend le mouvement que joe black
lake
mais il était vraiment minces s'est dit
jamais non le sai tentait de fabriquer
des fois t'es démoralisé aussi si tu
peux plus apte à malabo à la fin puis
c'est lui le matin seule baie bon ok on
y va de ses parts de marché faut-il vais
vous sortez vous poussez un peu l'air
défait ce mot qu'on fasse des trucs
comme john wayne lui lui il ya eu un
fils il ya eu est une coupe de 10 lui
c'est qu'en trois semaines il est
reporté
trois autres semaines mais c'est le fun
car il ya là deux qui partent en même
temps parce que ça fait un bail de web
services
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que j'ai quelque
chose qui m'est venue
vous avez fait quoi et alizée temps tout
d'abord fait le tour de la crotte
ouais on est faite des vignobles on a
rencontré en fait quand un talent au
vignoble la personne qui nous servait
son meilleur ami c'était comme le
propriétaire dit un des meilleurs restos
où manquera est en fait à chaniers
reproché de ou qu'on était pas qu'on
analyse sous pull up est le monsieur une
adoré ça qui nous a invité la semaine
après à deux ans de route je pense ça
ira clients ou à réthymnon ouais on est
allé l'année dans une dégustation de
vins tout l'après midi dès qu'ils font
c'est chaque année d'une console t elle
va aussi nous emmener manger dans un
restaurant complètement fou qui a coûté
2000 euros ou l'autre payer quand on
omet y était adorable le monsieur était
pin sec peu folle d'un oubli teruel
visitez facteurs en plus est à un plus
pour notre enfant j'ai fait un voyage de
rêve le précise lui en plus que tout on
est à ses derniers jo lactée lui avait
déjà fait pas mal de travaux à mener
cherchez pas les mêmes et on vous sortez
bonne un hôtel ceux ci offrirait de vous
offrir la question qu'on avait mais je
pense que ça joue une blague aussi à
aimer ça parce qu'ils étaient ça nous
dérange pas c'est nous mais qu avez-vous
croisé des québécois la boue et non
parce que ses habitants de croiser
quelqu'un qui suit l'émission est
éliminé mais je suis déjà arrivés à
quelques des excuses mais pas moi non
jamais je pensais que je pouvais pas
m'en sortir
ah ouais ouais mais c'était parce que
voulait pas sortir d'argent dans la
poche non plus nous aussi on a répété à
manille aussi sur mac et autres
raffineries sont rendu compte qu'ils
passaient par semaine c'est peut-être un
peu plus de jeu que admis avec capital
et il était même pas exclu mais il est
allé en thaïlande au full moon party et
demoiselles et que sa place n'était pas
des leurs au big chill à l'alinéa de
capter le ballon mais c'était le kit de
voyage
qui ont fait qu'ils ont su comment pêche
c'est l'interaction dans ce groupe b
ouais mais ça ce qu'elle est le monde et
ça c'est pas lui qui met en lui le gars
qui regardent l'émission est peu dire sa
perception de l'extérieur le team
attendez l'émission qu'est-ce-qui woippy
le juge boyer taille était que l'équipe
de voyages se prend le maquis salut au
total en voyage en tunisie
ouais ça doit te fous et débiles mais
c'est vite et jan cadieux aller retour
mais j'ai jamais j'avais jamais vu ça en
vrille de ma vie d'adulte boissezon
j'avais j'ai juste aller à vegas mais
c'est pas le même désormais la bataille
tel était le désert c'était vraiment où
est ce que j'aille en tennis avec jodie
mois on a dormi en plein milieu du
désert d'atacama
c'est complètement fou le moins est ce
que c'était quoi mettons votre
votre niveau de liberté pendant ce
voyage là est-ce que c'était tu n'étais
pas jérôme qui était en voyage
doucet non on avait les princes les
marques le prince marque le prince qui
est donc je sais qu'ils pillaient le nom
des gens du nom est légion blacks
non notre équipe de voyage parce que eh
bien nous nous sentons mieux la nounou
voyage est la vie et je te vois juste
quand on voyage à vienne chercher dans
les maisons à ta mère
le supporter seul avec la nounou
l'équipe voyage c'est sûr que quand on
dort on utile ou avec l'un de nous le
moi j'avais le temps des championnes et
dangereux bon avec toute l'équipe de
voyager mais on a fait comme 24 heures
pour sarah ont apprécié c'était une
journée une mi-temps variait de tournage
à vous intervient bon j'avais tout
voyager un peu avant ouais je voyage de
3 par année selon le dal et qui
s'appelle david c'est lui mais lui goût
dans le temps il y avait encore ils
terminent l'école l'alarmé pas que mon
châssis sodi mais avant c'est celui elle
à l'école travailler vraiment beaucoup
en la serrant prendre des petites
semaines minimum
mais tu y croies on aimait sa part des
croiseurs vegas en europe
mcewen ne s'était pas mes premiers tours
le l'appel de repartir quelques pas et
j'aurais vraiment aimé ce partir la fin
peut-être février je sais pas si je vais
pouvoir si mes projets finalement ça
m'étonne je pourrais peut-être pas mais
et je pourrais peut-être pas mais
j'aimerais ça allait passer une semaine
sans téléphone
mais sinon est ce que je vais partir le
j'aimerais faire des croiseurs mois bah
ouais ouais c'est cool ouais doute on
avait parlé de faire une croisière en
alaska
or ça me tenterait tellement faire cela
mais toujours pendant l'été quand les
journées sont faux king longue
ok j'en croise en labo est ce que l'été
il fait possible si free est que ce
pacte est comme bien dit relax mais les
gens y sont fort qinglong jolis paysages
oui mon grand père est li de 3 à 1 à
participer un jour 88 ans d'aller en
antarctique mais noir ces malades
et oui maison
j'ai mon papier qui m'a dit qu'ils
voulaient qu'ottawa et l'année prochaine
parce que je suis pas allé ouais ok
c'est bon je vais voyager avec lui livre
le 5 heures il y avait tout était ok
pour supporter hawaï
finalement il s'est fait opérer à coeur
ouvert puis à papa chez les u18 pas pu
partir du mot non plus on va y aller
pour mon dernier voyage au t4 cabreta
moment donné mais l'année prochaine je
pense que c'est mon prochain peut-être
gros voyage que je pense que oui
j'aimerais aller très très cool bien
plus quand arrive la baule moi j'ai un
ami qui le fait
ces deux couples d'amis on loue un char
les sont promenés mais c'était comme une
20ème avec un canard dormait là frissons
prenez en toutes les îles de sa valeur
fou
hassan al karama le monde en mars
montrent aussi
je n'attends pas à wade et à la havane
west ham est vraiment vraiment les
fausses enfin béton c'est papa qui bouge
ou tel crime faq beau football voilà
vivre un petit j'avais vraiment bon
ouais ouais drame rastel moi c'est ce
qui fait mouche à la musique s'est fait
qu' il faut la musique live au fil des
missions ya pas mal - ouais ok on va
tripler votre note
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut te
souhaiter
juste l'amour du ballon la france mais
non sinon eh ben je sais pas je pourrais
je le savais mais après ça moi j'ai
juste pu être fatigué puis est en pente
et puis que tout mes choses avaient bien
pour de vrai pays que j'espère que mon
petit projet là je veux vraiment et
j'espère te manquer je vais pouvoir
faire découvrir sa vague et je ne sais
pas que ça fonctionne je souhaite que
david soit gentil avec toi
oui vraiment beaucoup
ouais ouais pourquoi mais ça tombe trop
et je me coucherai ma journée puis le
bain je me réveille je pense à plein de
trucs puis je sais pas j'ai comme trop
d'idées dans ma tête puis finalement je
me lève le matin et je m'en suis même
plus de ce que j'ai pensé de toute la
nuit mais c'est tout le sens n'est pas
mieux de te lever et à écrire ce pigeon
coucherait face à face au non ferme et
un an avec un crayon papil way d'un
téléphone c'est comme ça va travailler
ses chéris mais j'ai les yeux fermés
mais ouais non j'ai vraiment besoin
mais là j'ai failli machina mais a tenu
une pareille
mais la tonine un truc pour se former et
naturel français puis s'arrêtera m'a dit
que je trouve qu'ils se trouvaient un
peu parce qu'il a moins mais moi qui
joue cet ensemble c'est parce qu'au
début ça en prenait pas trop forte ça me
fait absolument rien fait que j'ai
compris la dose de plus puis j'ai dormi
comme un bébé hier mais un matin je me
suis réveillé un peu d'alcool comme en
dehors de nommer
je me rappelle quand j'étais à bali
quand je t'ai pendant l'émission le
droit de dormir mais comme un débit
tournai tellement ouais mais dans la
pire chose qui pourrait arriver si jane
et webkit du genre élimination
l'histoire plus des procédures pas ça
tourne ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne en
stop quand je suis sorti ça m'a pris un
certain temps capable de vraiment dormir
com - mais je pense que c'est celle là
est justement aujourd'hui suis allé voir
mon entraîneur il dit pris 20 livres là
bas ah ouais mais là j'ai reperdu que
pas grand chose à part manger la boule
en fait manger si c'est très beau b'art
gens là se fait des gaillards la
doudoune ou voiliers de façon jamais
quand vous voyez les tadjiks fromage
tout sur marc coma
mais non c 'est puis un matin ils me
disent on va bientôt aller à cause de
mon tous deux chez wauquiez citant sont
rythmés yates dans vos biens pillés
ouais non je suis un peu de sport salle
adorent mais aussi mais les faits sont
là je crois que c'est bon on enclenche
un petit je me donne à un moment ça va
bouger mais j'ai besoin de prendre du
temps vraiment pourrai m'entraîner puis
bien manger juste remis d'un papier puis
je vois ici que de l'alcool avec la
rétention et 5 août étant tous ces trucs
que j'ai combat pour faire attention il
faut juste qu'elle aussi on pense que
tout ça comme le ses côtés de sortir de
ça
[Musique]
je l'année passée à pareille date
quasiment je m'étais dit ok en fait mon
abonnement économique ne se finir
ça faisait un an hier paquet je me fais
un 30 jours où j'ai fait en 30 jours je
me suis remis relativement chaud
effective mais si dilain sauf qu'après
ce après mon 30 jours ces retombées à un
creusement pour m'entraîner jusqu'à
temps que là elle paye mon agent me dire
on a peut-être de quoi pour le marathon
de québec ce que j'ai fait ok que ça me
prenait seul objectif parce que sinon
c'est impossible que geof est ce que
j'ai dit le mot avec lui ça va être deux
fois semaine avec lui puis quelque chose
à suivre la maison petite soeur mais été
après j'ai dit au moins des élastiques
gens face de chez nous je reposerai de
quoi faire une demi heure à chaque matin
pendant les jours de semaine du mondial
je te le faire mais aller où james
gelfand travailler c'est impossible je
vais pas le djemaï on sait où c'est loin
de chez vous oui vraiment chef
cuisiniste mike day 2 quad en cuisine je
pense dans la maison et marcheurs et
d'aller chiner sida et en gaspésie puis
son ami ça se trouve à être la demi
soeur d'enjoy mais non je pense que
c'est la merde njoum sort avec le père
d'accueil
merci aux matchs en état les allers
retours pendant les fouilles depuis à
m'envoyer une seule fille de l acdic end
jouer si c'est bon maintenant que ça
marche pas être carte le
[Rires]
j'ai vraiment cool vraiment fait
attention à ses besoins je sais pas ce
que j'allais vous y allez c'est pas
qu'aider mais au barça me dit mais j'ai
vraiment de moi je pense qu'ils prennent
leur temps masqué est à prendre dans ce
cadre est vraiment utile
en dehors des acquis patients des
papiers chez que lui sont dans ses plans
sur leur tournée c'est lui fini sa
maîtrise à québec sont place dans ses
plans au death leur tournée en gaspésie
être infirmier ah ouais j'ai pas
l'impression que les plantes catherine
c'est à dire merde surtout bon
maintenant si j'ai l'impression qu'il va
se passer mais tant elle a dit le fait
que la météo s'y habitue - gestion tant
la chance de se voir à ce point son fils
est ainsi fait que ça n'a pas aidé non
plus le développer une relation way a
longtemps mais je m'étais je pense sont
vraiment bons termes sinon peas will i
pour des projets petit fouet un qte à la
spatule à l'heure de vérité
non c'est pas dans ce non pas un cadeau
c'est là dedans le texte accorde pas
vaincu
yann puis julian son qui ont investi
sagement des métis i am et on compare le
e
comment sortent avec passion 2 julien
dansante est impossible sortant ou en
surpoids
la journée qui s'est fait éliminer sans
arrêt dans les extraits elle l'entendait
pas venez me rejoindre
parce qu'elle est parti juste deux jours
après moi plaignons défaut
qui a été le net tout ça la capote
finalement après deux jours plus de
stress plus rien avait aussitôt que j'ai
sorti des maisons le surf c'est tombé
j'ai vraiment appris à connaître que
c'est elle qui est dit je t'aime un
premier épisode allait vraiment appris à
le connaître pour devrait encore thq ya
naissante est vulnérable à beaupouyet
mes possibilités que richard girard
santé ce qu'elle avait besoin d'être a
souri ben ça marchait pas nos stocks
sont sortis je pense qu'ils se sont
vraiment appris à se connaître c'est
pour de vrai et puis sont venus chercher
dans vos poèmes à les primes on s'est
levé à l'équipe dans son ensemble
j'ai regardé jusqu'au brune a rien été
mais j'ai quand même temps mieux tipi
savez pas si vous l'avez en parler parce
qu'il était pauvre et les trois semaines
ensemble ils ont été parfaites je pense
vraiment qu'il couvrait gj croissante
aux cartes de noël
oui nous avons envoyé non non ça n'est
pas si yann arnaud en voyageant
pleinement mettons la soirée retard je
pense j'ai vu ça c'est guillaume pinault
qui montrait genre qu'il avait reçue à
qui lui en fait je pense que ceux qui
ont plus peut-être ceux qui ont plus
s'est arrangé avec passion difficile
mais même encore mais j'en ai vu plein
de semaine sentiment d'indécence et un
lit j'aurais géant kaleme tantaoui est
en tout cas c'était tellement touchée
qui manque et on en voyait vraiment
l'adhésion mais pas mieux si ça
fonctionne bien au delà c'est que multi
c'est tellement tu connais tellement
dans une constance fucked up que je
comprends ce que ça marche pas le tuer
après un nombre assez important c'est
nouveau ça marche et tant mieux mais
pour ça ça marche pas c'est ça la vraie
vie commence
vraie vie vraiment différente le tri
nations a imputé sa liste est d'abord
puis l'autre personne de l'aube a aussi
piloté si moindrement et le coupé pause
solide c'est vrai ça marche paul surtout
c'est surtout imed ben ouais mais bon
quand tu penses à bord le sait tout le
monde des humains dans une situation
bien du monde qui tacos tout le temps
puis tout est foutu dehors pendant que
son partenaire est en tournée de bord
ces atomes dans ta tête veut porter tout
temps les histoires en sorte de show de
réalité qui se font un
bon là la palette à ce niveau là ont
directement de rester grande de votre
année tant d'erreurs piano dessus et
j'ai aucune des noms ce sujet pense pas
autant dans les missions qui n'étaient
pas les mêmes buts c'est sûr mais au
niveau des barreaux et on est comme suit
on est quand même bien dans caudry parce
que là on est avec l'agencé ok y'a tout
à quelqu'un qui vient avec nous qui fait
un compte rendu ou qui ont aidé comme
rega se éviter c'est que reebok notre
hôtel mais je veux dire si je veux je
peux chanter à quatre pattes si je fais
ce que je veux rendu là bas c'est juste
que tes fautes faites attention à ton
image puis c'est ce que sais-je mais 408
de maçonnerie arraché mon parti mais
ouais on s'est fait avorter aussi t on à
partir de minuit mettez à 3,4 et encore
c'est peut-être mon ami l'annoncé puis
c'est bien correct je pense que c'est
juste qu'on s'est fait griffer latitude
mais ne sera pas contente
mais trente personnes n'ont pas commencé
de faire plus attention je pensais qu
est ce que vous êtes pour se saluer
taleb est aussi on était des personnes
et est maintenant lié autonome je pense
qu'on est capable d'aider potro et on va
le pion on se fait inviter facteurs
voilà moi non plus la sto hui on ne te
parler sous le poids de 15 la statue
d'un amour on ne parlait de moi c'est
quelque chose auquel pierre parceque je
me rappelle je t'ai au mariage david vos
joueurs puis sur les seuls mes potes qui
changent et ogero pis
j'ai amené un autre de mes amis jabbes
pour une série men et x games de prendre
concernant france italie en disant des
spas cytos hématome préféré le mystère
arraché complètement
j'ai fait de la story pêche d'espèces
tôt ce matin préféré plonger comme
publié la story voilà j'ai comme eu la
lucidité d'esprit un mince instant dans
la salle de bain puis de regarder la
story que je nageais la sto restée genre
préféré plein derrière c'est même pas
d'espacé taux qui joue les cibler des
fêtes
ah non mais maintenant supprimer plaide
me suis dit ok le tout venant ma poche
je te s'empilent et son jus qu'à 2 quad
à lyon le rapport rapport mais en même
temps c'est en même temps le stade ça
donne accès à au monde a une façade mais
sur ces points de facettes que je veux
montrer davantage si c'est pas grave
mais tu es si gentil papy c'est ça je te
fais vraiment vraiment mécanique et le
monde parle de mes seins parce que je
suis fatigué je sais pas qu'est ce
qu'ils m'ont dit georges et du
maquillage
si j'avais mal et puis on s'entend
quelqu'un quand les lumières souffre
dans un bar déjà mais à temps plein
potentiel
jamais je n'ai pas vraiment aimé ton
olivie primeau qui faillit jamais
arraché
préférence même ils ont connu de même
attali c'est pas grave et boy paris je
pense que même mais c'est drôle parce
que à l'heure de vérité le quand j'ai vu
j'ai du monde et une aux mains comme toi
on recrée yquem kahn camille ou du parti
ce matin avec une deux trois et
d'inviter y est drôle et fil des mois
l'huile vraiment beaucoup le t6 jusqu'à
ouais c'était moi mais certaines
personnes sont venues une semaine qui
ont marqué de ce mets ton michael est
beau il est déplacé de la ramener sur
son passé mais écoute lui aussi est ce
un adorable sérieux moi je suis
sollicité avec passion double play je
tiens les cheveux puis jamais le voit à
lui je vois capoté mais que je bois
t.imo vraiment devant tout le monde
avant tout je sais c'est qu'à donner à
léo ce pôle à cette journée le laisser
revenir en pleurs à imprimer il m'avait
entrer dedans mais d'une façon je sais
pas si c'est oui ou c'est finalement le
monde me disait attentes et tu vas voir
lui il fait des faits des shows en
france puis et télé réalité sont toutes
script et son stand g callen t'es moche
on ne peut pas être une mannequin gentil
of fame c'est sauter débuté dans ma tête
c'est ce puits la première fois je les
ai vus tout cas me montrer ses enfants
tchèques eux mêmes ont douté de rien à
mon pauvre s est un amoureux puis y est
capable de pleurer crier en 30 secondes
lui c'est un acte un compromis pour la
cabine à midi télé-réalité sans caméras
deux secondes par les opca baguette et
moi je l' ai tout le temps vu comme ça
mais quand j'ai parlé des heures et des
heures de connaissance et puis y'a
durable mont diamand mais c'est vrai que
vous pensez que c'est un acteur engagé
pour trois mois le public ont décollé
d'ici mai
non je savais pas jusqu'à protéger dudus
coke
je m'excuse michael que je capote bref
son départ la scène finale se sent comme
s'il était un héros d'une tragédie
grecque
joppy le mnj comme toi ah non mais tout
le monde on était malheureux seigneur
moi je regarde je regardais la baule
s'est brillamment le jean bart oui
paiement d'une courte présence le corps
présence mais d'une intensité incroyable
de mesurer l impact est content d'avoir
passé par là ouais vraiment mais je leur
ferai pas deux fois de suite maintenant
systar fort mais sur l'éducation ce soit
une deuxième fois
mais si j'avais à le faire et le temps
du recul c'est la fresque 1% avec la
conscience de ce qu'ils te le tuent
leurs fruits un geste est pas j'ai aimé
faire ça sans savoir pour pouvoir gérer
non je ne ferai pas avec la conscience
tu leur prends pas sa chance ou non mais
si j'ai un regret côté si c'était le
sens avant je leur ai centrale pour
qu'est-ce que ça m'a apporté
personnellement et autres lemay avec le
maintenant je pense côté style on paie
j'ai trouvé de partir tout le monde même
des deux machines familiale si ma
famille j'ai voit une fois par semaine
fact et non je leur ferai peut-être ça
j'ai trouvé c'est ce que j'ai trouvé
l'épisode mais ouais je referais sans
savoir ouais vraiment 100% défiant de de
ton passage en temps parcours mais
vraiment merci beaucoup de mes amis oui
on peut très vite et mes amis c'est la
beauté c'est qu'on est forcé de jaser
c'est une polémique rectorat aux pieds
ses rangs que toujours ce qu'on
s'entendait quelqu'un pendant deux
heures de temps
jamais annoncé sa fine jamais merci
[Musique]
wright podcast officiel exclusif et une
pour pour tous les abonnés beaucoup de
nouveaux abonnés voilà ici salut merci
d'être le téléphone
- petite vague dépêché un téléphone
c'est les encourage
mesa ça nous encourage ça nous fait
réaliser qu'il ya du monde qui aime ce
qu'on fait - et qui veulent nous
encourager pour qu'on continue fait que
nous ça fait juste nous encourager à
continuer dans ce sens hier sans cela on
vient juste d'en tourner un visiteur
avec qui veut que les pitchounes mon
petit exclusif où on était avec
guillaume pignons de pin hole humoristes
on se passionne nous aurons par l'acam
ses collègues pinault d'ailleurs on
vient juste sorti assez frêle mais
semble que c'est une icône le plus de
fun à date
ouais c'est mettons à la vibe les
téléphones mobiles dans notre bail ben
ouais c'est lui qui est le pardonner kit
aéro ce théâtre du puy santé rien parce
que j'ai pas écouté aucun on dépose en
direct de new delhi jo 4 3 non non j'ai
juste une idée du personnage qui ont
déprimé je crois bt en m16 mettons que
tant qu'ils viennent finir tu écoutes au
début on dirait que ça peut divertir
métier c'est vraiment ce qui pas bhl ses
sauts depuis ce soir je suis guéri il
manquait rien tu as visité où j'ai même
encore aujourd'hui juste le fait qu' on
parle encore beaucoup d'occupations
d'objets à se doter dans ma vie pour
dans un col ces puits pour le réputé
seul même si chez qui le demande qui ont
mis du temps pour faire ses débuts dès
bons gags sur moi host et je manquais un
peu normal et de passer à autre chose
aussi avec l'effectif tarnais l'émission
ou des courts en dur et même si j'écoute
un peu docteur un peu mais je décroche
est vraiment victime et on est ce que tu
te mettre à leur place et fo de
l'empathie ou d'un genre je me suis fait
prendre à embarquer puis à oublier que
c'est un show bon mettons été gelée que
j'écoutais le mien était comme en
tabarnak spawn même ça se passe le
montage pleut on dirait je l'écouté
comme une télésérie comme moi vraiment
c'est quelle bande font oies et puis je
pense que c'est une bonne affaire c'est
juste
j'ai l'impression en piste c'est
drôlement plus largement avec les
téléréalités pardon hein j'ai
l'impression que les gens les déjà
coetzer en prenant ce beaucoup trop au
sérieux
vraiment en faisant comme si les
personnes qui voyait c'était des vrais
personne parce que c'est pas tes pas une
vraie personne quant à bord at-elle été
si passe à travers le spectre de
tellement de caractère sur sion était
loin d'être une vraie personne est un
personnage puis il ya trop de monde
prennent ça pour du cash puisse a cessé
c'est dommage que je pense que ça les
principaux perdants l'adage penser ce
qu'ils font c'est ce qu'ils font qui qui
sont reconnaître comme un personnage
mais admettons que tu vois si tu croises
la rue par exemple claude legault se
veut pas l'appeler fabien de dans une
galaxie près de chez vous tissez claude
legault ouais puits de secours sis à
passenans tu le sais que fabien c'est un
personnage t puis j'ai l'impression que
le problème est que les télé réalité
c'est que le monde ils vont me croise
une rue puis ils vont penser que le
personnage qui ont vu ces - wallace qui
font pas la distinction mais je les
comprends parce que c'est sûr que quand
tu l'as vécu tu sais quand nos jeunes
puissent et ce qui t'a nan je pense puis
je pense que vraiment plus de mon pays
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est le monde
sur notre patronne qui font voir site
parce que pense que le monde qui nous
écoutons un raisonnement plus plus
poussé que celui le oui je pense que
c'est une problématique mais c'est que
là c'est vraiment une pro matic pour les
gens qui le font le point récemment pour
eux les choses aux 35
mais pour les gens qui le font ça peut
être peut être temps d'en médecin si
ceux-ci claqué faudra prendre le temps
laisse puis ce qui m'étonne calmes ces
trente secondes de ta journée qui dure
24 heures le team et en vient à parler
guillon mais je peux leur parler sillage
avec holly couturier fait auditionner
pisser dessus
voilà chicane avec l'autre que leila
baveux petit soupir delà des fessées
dessus mais cinq minutes après il tenait
la brise des je t'aime qui jouent au
ping pong en même temps ses appuis plus
tu relativises plus te dis que c'est
pour ça que tu as signé tu savais répit
que c'était un deal constance avec sa
blessure je passe à autre chose qu'à
mais si j'avais pas besoin d'écouter au
des plus même si guillaume est d'être
sûr qu'il allait voir son choix place le
temps presse
[Musique]